please welcome the director of the
confession tanel tomb
oh
believe me making a speech is way harder
than making a film
but
but
making a film is like
giving a birth not not that i know
anything about it
but
and with those who have made a film or
or given birth
they know that it's
it's
um
not a particularly easy process
so it takes planning at least in
filmmaking we do
and then it takes hard work
and
it also takes luck
but it's the most
beautiful process so
if somebody knows it notices your film
or even considers it
worthy of an award
it must feel like your
child smiling to your for the first time
and
it is the most rewarding thing
and you start to think that
maybe i'm not the worst filmmaker in the
world
so
i would like to thank the academy
it's a real honor to be here and receive
this award and i've always wanted to
thank the academy so
sorry
um
all of us here know as well that no film
could be conceived alone
also like with the babies
so the most important people for for a
film
are my collaborators of whom i would
like to
bring a special thanks to i want to
thank caroline my writer i want to thank
luke davide mariana paul emmy giacomo
you see joe juan everyone who worked on
the film and of course my actress luis
and joe
i couldn't have done it without you guys
and
i would also like to thank my school the
national film and television school
um i'm really proud i could do this
for school
so the award is still here okay good
and i'm extra proud
i could do this estonia so i'm estonian
if you didn't figure out my thick accent
i'm actually not from england
and
i want to thank all my supporters from
there from eastern as well and
especially my parents who have been
always there for me
so
thank you again
the academy
survey regular
and um
now i'm a bit confused because because i
was just writing the speech on three
papers and i don't know whether i'm
missing something or not
but anyways thank you everyone i mean
everyone